[Music]
on today's show
we talk about how couples can rebuild
their life
after life-altering transitions we also
talk to an
awesome mom of adult children who's
really frustrated by their decisions and
choices
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up welcome everybody to the
dr john delony show
i am john and when i say welcome
everybody
you 22 people know who you are sitting
probably most of y'all are in the circle
just looking at each other
because y'all are doing some form of
community service and
the judge in your community thought it'd
be hilarious to make you have to listen
to this show as part of your
criminal punishment we're glad you're
here and you can tell for those who've
been with us for a long time we have
moved up from 17 to 22.
we gained uh four or five new followers
we're excited
we are doing somersaults here in the
studio hey a couple of things before we
get going on the show
number one if you're new to us we're so
glad you're here it's awesome
and i keep saying we it's just me here
um actually it's not it's zach and
kelly james who's also
at funrunner.com.net org if you want to
go check out his website and um hey we
talk about mental health we talk about
relationships we talk about
the things that you're struggling with
that you're walking through
and um we take real calls live calls
from you i'll walk alongside you and we
will help figure this out thing
this thing out together
uh before we get going though i do want
to talk about this
um you all know i hate selling stuff
it's just part of the deal
but a few months ago i came out with a
book it's a really thin book it's like
80 pages
and it's called redefining anxiety man i
just kept having
some people kept calling about i got
anxiety i got anxiety and got anxiety
and one day i popped off in a meeting
hey anxiety is not the issue
and everyone around me said huh and so
we wrote a quick book on it
it has taken off a life of its own we
all
were scratching her head when it made
the best seller list and now i'm
starting to get
these really remarkable emails with
entire police department leadership
teams holding a copy of the book
of counseling centers and medical
centers buying these things by the case
to pass out to their clients
this book's 10 bucks it's it costs it's
it's low cost it's easy to read
and it really just cuts through all the
nonsense it doesn't it's not a
four inch book on all the
neuroscience and mumbo jumbo and
theoretical blab
it just gets right to it and so if you
know somebody who's struggled with
anxiety
um it's a it's a it's good it's helping
a lot of folks i'm grateful for
everybody
if this book has meant something to you
if it's helped you out if it's helped
you
be able to communicate better with
someone that you love man let me know
because man i do this show and then i go
home and i live out in the woods and i
don't
pay attention to a lot of stuff and so
it means a lot to me when you say hey
this little 10 investment helped me and
my wife talk better it helped me
understand my kids it helped me and my
workplace get along better it's awesome
so that's it 10 bucks johndolone.com you
can get a copy of this book
all right let's go to the phones let's
take the first call from
kyle in paducah kentucky
kyle what is up well it's an interesting
day
um it's like it is
damn broke with us and everything has
come my direction all at once
that's not what i'm calling hey why not
hey let's talk about it it's happening
no no no no you got my name in my little
city so we can't discuss all that
hey come on i'll lie if you want to
that's part of the fun here it's got
my name's on the show it's cool i'm
hoping people hear this that know me
uh it might help somebody okay so bring
it on man what's going on
i have um an ongoing challenge having
discussions uh
meaningful discussions with my wife okay
our conversations
who is a who is currently walking out in
her 11th year
of brain cancer okay so did she have a
surgery
back in the day that altered her
cognitive capacity in 2010
she had a seizure in the move a night
and found out it was a brain tumor
on her right temporal lobe as
more of a mass it wasn't the root style
turned out to be anaplastic astrocytoma
had a craniotomy followed by radiation
chemo the whole nine yards yeah um
she came out with i mean with memory
impact
uh physical stuff's fine
motor skills are pretty good
she i mean that was trauma to the whole
body oh
absolutely beyond any of my imagination
um and it has just changed things yeah
so
so is 11 years into this and
it makes it for some challenging days
that's right man
so let me get to let me ask a few more
questions just
physiological questions did did the
surgery
alter her personality in any way did it
alter the way she sees the world or is
this
more a trauma response she lives an
anxious life a fearful life
or the other way it's just wheels off
now now we are
going to sprint to the end here because
she got to peer over the edge
tell me about these these changes okay
so
this was in our fourth year of marriage
uh we dated for about a year beforehand
so my
i have been uh compared
trying to nail down what some drastic
changes have been
but because of my no my limited amount
of time knowing her beforehand
i have i've known her a lot longer post
craniotomy okay okay but don't get don't
talk to
i talked to her friend yesterday another
friend that's known her longer than me
and asked her
and this might have been the first time
i asked her this and she said she used
to be a go-getter
okay um and now she's not
um but so hey kyle
go ahead i don't want i don't want don't
go back in
and try to recreate a puzzle that you
didn't experience
tell me what you experienced you knew
her for four years or five years or six
years and then you got
yeah what and then you've known her
since so
what happened before you met her doesn't
matter
very much to me what have you
experienced
and why is it what did you have caution
there she is very cautionary
fear uh anything
anything um
it's hard for me to discuss things of
the future like my dreams my aspirations
with her
because she begins to see herself as a
burden and the anchor that keeps me from
going that route
and um we didn't have we didn't
experience that beforehand
so what in the last before what in the
last decade
has communicated to her that she's some
sort of a burden
oh the fact that she has not
um she went on disability after it
and got it get on just lickety-split
um and then they denied her
and because we have a daughter and
uh it was more we'd already gotten that
rhythm of her being a stay-at-home mom
when she lost disability my income was
enough to cover and take care of all the
needs and stuff like that
she didn't have to go to work she wanted
if she wanted to
um which i think she was fearful at it
she was kind of hesitant but
um she
there was not the need it would created
more headaches
because she would just want to go back
into for all of us because she was
wanting to go back into retail at the
mall which would
be crazy schedules and everything else
we just gotten stuck not stuck we gotten
comfortable in that rhythm
of her being at home it sounds like you
got comfortable with her being at home
okay is that fair or not fair yeah oh
that's very fair
because i'm trying to drill down here's
the thing it's really common when
somebody has
a life-altering moment a brain tumor is
one of those things
brain cancer is one of those things a
traumatic brain injury is one of those
things right
and there are a million different
versions of that the first time you have
a heart attack first time you have an
anxiety attack
any of those things somebody you love
dies in a car wreck we have these
moments
that that i call before and after
moments i was this way
up until here gotcha and the challenge
when when you have a before and after
moment and you're married
and you got kids or you've got close
family
is everybody around you often
wants to go back to the way things were
and you've had this
giant lightning bolt experience you're
different now
and everyone around you is says well
now that you're up and walking now that
you're up and running around now that
you're out of the hospital fill in the
blank
now we can go back to what was and what
i
often tell folks who experience a trauma
especially when it's acute right like
we're right in the middle of it or just
coming out of it is
everything is different now even if it
looks the same even if you
drive home in the same car you went to
the hospital and everything's different
and so you have to
excavate what was and rebuild something
completely new
and so what i'm trying to drill at
drill down here is this is a decade ago
and
something along the way has communicated
to her
and i'm not blaming you for it i'm
asking you may be a part of it i'm
guessing you are not that you're a bad
guy just part of it
something has communicated to her over
time that her what she wants
what her vision of the future is what
y'all's vision of the future is
she's weighing you she's slowing you
down right
right and my guess is your kids 10 i
mean not my guesses but your kid's 10
years older now
the whatever the things she wanted to do
are now just i'm so sorry or it's just a
thing
and when you can't fight and you can't
you can't fight brain cancer right you
got to go through
chemo and do those things but once
you're done you can't have a fistfight
with it
you can't run from it because it's in
your body and so what's the other thing
when you're under attack and you can't
flee and you can't fist fight it
your body just goes it goes into neutral
that's right
it just shuts down it freezes right it
tries to not be detected by the world
and another word for frozen is an anchor
right
so what i'm asking you is what about you
have you not how have you contributed to
her feeling like she
is of value her dreams are your dreams
and
your dreams or her dreams or have you
contributed to a narrative that
she just needs to get on board hey
you'll take care of it
your vision's important and she can come
along for the ride
probably both of those okay um
a lot of i mean i'm a dreamer yeah and i
might have
a different ambition in life
every year and i've got to be grounded
because i
am just i'm at card carrying add
um full blown so i've got a shed full of
previous hobbies that i'm not ever going
to touch again um
most likely so i um
so that's a context not an excuse yeah
i'm not i'm
yeah i'm i'm not helpful in that okay um
so here here's what i'm asking there's
there is no cognitive
impairment meaning my oldest friend on
planet earth the oldest friend i have
is a traumatic brain injury survivor has
very little ability to develop short new
short-term memories
and often collapses spaces of up to 20
years
and so sometimes out of nowhere i'll get
an email about hey
here's something that happened the other
night and it happened 20 something years
ago
he's got legitimate cognitive impairment
and he's working his
butt off in an extraordinary way to
continue to work towards it so there's
that's one thing
sounds to me like your wife is suffering
from a
long-term compression of
who she has become post-surgery that she
doesn't have any cognitive impairment
she's just been living under water for a
decade um
learning new skills i see when i observe
her trying to learn something new
if she is if it if it presents itself
with some type of resistance or
challenge she will back away from that
and just
her spirit crumbles in a sense okay um
she feels like failure um okay
so that there's a part of me that wants
to jump in there and be like okay we can
push through this
um but there's another part of me just
says no i've got to let her push through
this
and wait until she asks me for help okay
and then back away again
so i want to present you a third option
i want to present your third option
one of those is to jump in and solve it
right
right and i think your impulse there
like that's my impulse whenever i see my
wife struggling with something or my
kids
somebody that i love struggling
something i want to jump in and solve it
then i've also learned that me solving
things
is not helpful most of the time right it
it makes me be able to get in the car
faster but it doesn't help my kids grow
up
it it short circuits my wife's
development right all those things the
third option is
i can create an environment where i am
stable
where she can be so anchored in
that she can try and get frustrated and
repel off the side and she knows i'm not
going anywhere
she knows i'm not gonna spend money that
we don't have that i'm not gonna
fly by night something else and the
moment she gets her foot grounded i'm
off to the next thing and the next thing
and the next thing
creating a world where she just quits
repelling off the side because i'm not
even a stable
i'm not a stable rock anymore right not
saying that the guy's got to be the rock
i'm seeing both people have to do it to
each other
right for each other okay and so the
third option is just to create a
universe that she
is a part of co-creator universe is a
better way to say that
or man you can rappel off the edge and
try your crazy schemes
and they're balanced and stable enough
where she can
try hard things fail be frustrated get
up again tomorrow
try them again right does that makes is
that you see a whole third option here
it's not an either or thing that that
actually took place this summer
she well because of my procrastination
and lack of
want to do it she decided well yeah she
decided and got tired of waiting for me
to paint the living room and she painted
it and it was
excellent and it feels like a victory
for her
oh same like i have applauded her and
praised her
since that happened awesome um so what
would be awesome
is if you could create a world where she
doesn't have to violate core values of
hers
to to be able to accomplish something
that an accomplishment for her isn't
also an act of rebellion
an act of throwing up her hands and say
i can't count on this guy i'm gonna have
to go do it
right okay because that ends up that
that is
her cutting that cord and just saying
i'm gonna fly to the bottom and i hope i
land
and this time she landed she landed
great but that does not
tell me that the ecosystem's healthy
there right
so yeah backing out at ultimately
how do you communicate with your wife
who's experienced this before and after
thing you're looking at a decade now
right yes my guess is y'all are both
exhausted
and on the back end of exhaustion
becomes high frustration
and high frustration leads to people
creating alt universes
that don't include each other right
yes and i have experienced that okay um
and i went through a phase of that so
yes
and then on the other end of that is
resentment
and very few relationships come back
from resentment
because that a fancy word for resentment
is an anchor
which is what she's describing i'm out
yes whatever you want dude
it's cool that makes sense um yes
that got me into recovery back in 2014.
awesome
awesome and i have loved recovery it is
and so
because of that um
i have dove into recovery and so anytime
that i try to bring that up
it is received as trying to fix
and that's not the intention of it so
i'm kind of in that weird place of
i don't know i just
i don't know what to do have you had
that conversation
[Music]
sad scary place right yeah you're right
there
it is that um so listen i think i have
attempted to and i think every time it
has turned out to go
awry and so i have just gotten gun shy
to even bring it up
okay so here's what you got to do that's
fair enough yeah that's super fair
enough yeah absolutely absolutely
so here's what i'll tell you you are on
a you are on a
bullet train towards forcing each other
into an either or conversation here in
the next few years
okay okay and that's not a place that
you want to end up
it doesn't sound like it sounds like you
really love your wife you've been
through recovery now
and you want the same healing for your
whole household that you're experiencing
and and and is that fair yes okay myself
all right so it's awesome that you want
to stay married to this woman that you
love this woman and now you're saying
all right i'm out of tools
i'm out of i don't know what the next
move is and whenever you don't know what
the next move is
with someone that you really love and
care about the next move
is saying out loud with them i don't
know what the next move is but i'm all
in
okay and that vulnerability think of
yourself as a porcupine
running through life and that's the
moment that porcupine rolls over
and on exposes his belly and says you
can hurt me
but i know that my approach isn't
working
and i'm too invested in you i'm too
invested in us
to take one more step in the wrong
direction so i'm just gonna stop
okay right and that cannot calm brother
on a
on the back of a fight it can't come at
the back end of a disagreement
it's got to be a planned conversation
that she knows is coming that you know
is coming
that everybody can come in with all the
guards down
because when somebody challenges us all
guards up we go back to our old routines
i'm protecting me you're protecting you
i'm good
and my guess is you try to solve stuff
because you've got lots of answers and
you've got lots of experiences
and she just goes into neutral and says
whatever dude and pulls the car over on
the
side
right so do this here's here's the step
i want you to take her out let her know
hey
i wanna talk i wanna have a dreaming
conversation about the future
where i don't talk i listen
and you know what even better kyle even
better because my
guess is at this point a decade after
brain cancer when you start
talking i bet your wife checks out
you sound like a guy who's i mean you
said you a you've got a garage full of
projects
you've got a lot of words and a lot of
explanations and i recognize this
because i'm you brother
so i want you to write your wife a
letter write write her a letter
and leave it on her pillow and the
letter will say something like
i love you more than anything
and i'm committed to you
above all else i also know that i'm
not helpful i'm hard to be around
i've tried to solve lots of stuff that
hasn't been mined to solve
and i've tried to create a future for
our family that that often doesn't
include you
it includes you but you writing co-pilot
to wherever i'm taking us
instead of us both sharing driving
responsibilities into this vision of the
future
and so i want to go out to breakfast one
morning one saturday morning we'll get a
babysitter
go out to breakfast one saturday morning
and i just want to listen
i want to listen to you i want you to
tell me your story once you tell me how
you felt the last 10 years
i want you to talk to me and be
vulnerable be open
and commit in that breakfast that
not saying a lot of answers it's doing a
lot of listening
and what you'll probably find out is
after a decade
you had a before and after too you
almost lost your wife
and you went into solution mode and you
went into addiction mode and then you
went into recovery mode
and probably both of you haven't healed
from that initial
incident and then you've just taken a y
and now you find yourself two inches
apart on each from on a couch from each
other but you're 2000 miles away you
live in separate lives your roommates
right
and you're probably gonna need to get a
marriage counselor which is tough for
some
uh from a respectable tough guy from
paducah kentucky it is
but you're gonna go first you're gonna
tell your wife hey i wanna do this
because i want to
i want to be in the long run with you in
the long run on this deal
and i'm out of tools we got to get
somebody that's going to teach us some
new tools teach me some new tools teach
me how to listen
teach you how to get that car out of
neutral get back into drive
and me not trying to reach over and grab
your wheel while you're driving all the
time
but it's brother all comes back to you
being vulnerable and you go in first
and saying the road that we're on we
know where this is going to lead
we're not being successful or not
and i want to step back and recreate
this whole house
and that starts with me saying i'm sorry
let's try again let's go do this
and kyle if you do that man
she may say i don't even know who you
are brother what'd you do with my kyle i
want him back
or she may just say i don't have
anything to say everything's fine it's
all good and if that happens then kyle
you say
well i appreciate you i'm gonna go to
counseling i'm gonna go learn some new
tools i'd love it if you join me
because at the end of the day all you
can do is take care of you
but it starts you being brave and kyle
let's just be honest
you making this call was brave i
appreciate you
not a lot of guys in paducah kentucky
are going to say hey
i love this lady i love my life i want
to honor her the best way i can and i'm
out of options i'm out of tools
you're a brave guy now you got to go
look that one woman that you love you
committed to in the eye and say
whoo
let's start healing from the floor up
and i'm going first
all right we'll be right back this is
the doctor john dolone show
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy
video chat text chat phone counseling
it's a licensed therapist whenever and
wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com slash
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available all the time
this is for you
your family and for everyone else that's
coming your way take care of your mental
health go to betterhelp.com
all right let's go to sarah in saratoga
springs
new york what's up sarah how are you
hi john how are you so good what's going
on good
um i have a question for you um last
year
in april my husband and i are both 31
years old
last year in april my husband almost
died from an
undiagnosed heart condition whoa um and
we are sort of a year out from that and
my husband is struggling with the
lifestyle changes that come with that
um so i just needed some advice to how
to help him through that
oh that's so hard sarah that's so hard
okay so tell me about what happened
yo just putting along and all of a
sudden whoa
um i was in my office one morning it was
early morning around seven o'clock
and i heard what sounded like snoring in
our bedroom so i thought because my
husband snores and i was like oh okay
but it was getting louder and i walked
in and
he couldn't breathe yeah suffocating
yeah
that's a terrifying sound when someone's
it was a congestive heart failure almost
uh
yeah his um when i was on the phone with
the
paramedics he actually um his heart
stopped
um and he like turned purple and his
face was like
you know not in a human form um
and he like stopped moving and then
um what i can only be described as a
miracle from god is
he like sat straight up and and
woke right back up wow um
[Music]
and they thought it might have been a
seizure but then they
figured out it was an issue with his
heart and he was in the cardiac icu for
two weeks and he had a failed
surgery that he almost died from and
then his heart stopped five
other times and they had to jump him
um and they finally figured out that it
was a medication that he had been put on
for depression that kicked he like he
had this heart problem
but the medication basically like kicked
it into gear
um so he has an icd
in him now to help if anything else
happens
um have you had you'll have to go
through regular checkups for that has
there been any
has it caught anything or is everything
working fine now
everything seems to be working fine um
his doctors
um told him he has to really change the
way he eats
and his drinking and smoking and all
that kind of stuff and they
they see him he has two cardiac doctors
and they
see him every three months okay so
before we get to him
before we get to you living with
somebody who won't make behavioral
changes which is a
nightmare talking to you sarah i
know you're gonna do that hey listen
i've heard that
sound before and outside of the scream
of a young person
that is a sound that is like no other
it's that sound that sounds like snoring
but it's a
i've heard it called the death rattle it
is a very particular
noise that when you're with other um
emergency personnel
everybody kicks up because they know
what that means
that is a trauma for you have you worked
through this have you been
able to talk to somebody to experience
this or have you just been running full
tilt since this moment
i have talked to two different i've been
going to therapy since i was 14 so i've
been in consistent therapy throughout it
okay um and with one of my therapists we
worked through
like we did the thing of like what if he
had died and we like worked through that
of like
how would i be and stuff like that but
i've never
i guess that's the moment when it
happened
i've not heard of that therapy
yeah it was it it was that seems
almost as traumatizing wow
okay well whatever to each his own maybe
maybe one day i'll call your therapist
just to have a conversation that sounds
fascinating
it's like ah man in your desk near-death
experience
let's totally experience that right
[Laughter]
yeah wow okay to each his own right um
yeah so here's the thing
so you know this you've been in therapy
i
less therapeutic more
you having a friend to sit with and just
be able to
weep openly you've been holding that
your body's probably been holding its
breath for a year
yes you are correct and i and i every
time i walk into the bedroom
yep every time you hear a sound yep
every time you walk out and you're doing
something and you hear a weird whatever
or in the middle of the night you wake
up and hear him snoring
and you reach out to put your hand on
his chest like
that is your body in fight or flight
okay
and until you let that cycle through
your body and you
completely go that was then and this is
now
yeah you are intentionally
not changing your behaviors okay that's
a mean way to put a trauma response um
but i just think a lot of us live with
trauma and we just assume that's just
the way that's going to be and it's not
but until you process that not by
imagining what happened if he just been
dead
that's a weird way to experience trauma
but
you got to let the cycle run through
okay meaning there's gonna come a moment
when you're gonna have to reckon with
those feelings
the fact that you can't control whether
he stays alive or not
whether you can't control
whether you control very very little in
your life is basically what
handling that trauma response letting it
work itself all the way through and you
can finally exhale
you can finally sleep through the night
um
whatever that looks like for you i just
want to highly highly highly recommend
that for you okay
okay otherwise you're living an
electrified life
and that shortens your lifespan too
yeah right you can't fully sit in the
joy you can't fully
laugh all the way into your guts you
can't
fully enjoy sexual intimacy you can't
fully get into life because your body is
still waiting for the other shoe to drop
right right
and as you can see i've heard that noise
and it sets me off
right and very few things sarah set me
off and that noise does
it's terrifying right wasn't saying no
one's ever talked to me about the noise
yes or like commiserated with me over
the noise
and that's and that's it like like if i
hear something that sounds like that
noise i like get out of my chair and i
like go around the corner
like my cat scratching on something but
like i think
something's happening and so your body
now has
to think of it as um
um an emergency response team and it
created a new unit
that all it does 24 7 365 is scan your
environment for sleep i mean for that
for that noise and it will sleep less
because it's looking for that noise and
it will
not pay attention to your work and your
writing and to the movie and to sex and
all those things because it's scanning
the environment for the noise
until you can go in and process that
trauma and tell that
unit of your brain i'm good i'm good
so do i process that with a friend or
with a therapist or
both and that's everyone does it
differently some people take a journal
out to the mountains and they come back
all better
and some people have to go through a
seeking safety program where they work
through the actual event
and relive it and they've got some way
they learn ways to
breathe through challenges so when those
when it shows up
how you can work through it and then you
become it becomes almost instantaneous
it's learning a new set of skills right
that's what it is um and
everybody does that differently but it's
you knowing i am consciously seeking
this
new set of skills so that when this
thing happens
i'm good and then i'm moving on yeah
right and then when you process
that then you're going to have to deal
with you're going to be walk driving
your car someday
in the picture of him sitting up in bed
that terrifying look on his face
will flap flashback in your head and
then you're going to learn to control
your thoughts
and say nope i'm not choosing to focus
on that and you're going to have some
backup thoughts that you go to directly
and then you're going to realize well i
can control my thoughts most of the time
i can't control the lightning bolts but
i can control
whether i meditate on that and let my
body set off on an entire fear response
based on something that's not going to
happen again
right and then you got to make peace
with it can all happen again which leads
to
the nightmare of living next to somebody
who's received a terminal behavior
change
who just won't change right right
meaning
if you don't stop doing x y and z you're
gonna die
and they go got it and they go home and
jump right back into x y or z
right so tell me about your side of that
like like what he's doing or how i'm
dealing with it both
um well he has definitely changed
his diet um and he lost
40 pounds wow very cool
doing yeah he's he's very like
healthy i would say in his body but i
notice when stress comes up he goes back
to his old eating habits of like you
know the greasy stuff like
all the stuff you don't want to eat i
know but sarah
listen cheeseburgers make sadness go
away for a minute
it's delicious i know it just
shoves all of my sad feelings down
right yes it does so good and then after
a while a few hours they start coming
back up
more cheeseburgers yes
awesome so he's trading one thing for
another huh
yes okay um and then they told
him his doctor told him you can have a
drink
at your 50th wedding anniversary you can
have a drink at your daughter's wedding
but other than that
you should never drink again and he i
would say he was like
a pretty social drinker he was not an
alcoholic by any means but like he would
have a couple of beers out with friends
he enjoyed a good whiskey
and it was very social for him yep
so the thought of not having that
he can't process and we
got to the year mark and we decided that
a year we would talk about it
and at a year i said you know i feel
comfortable with you having
one drink or two drinks a month but i
don't know if i'll be comfortable with
anything more than that
because the doctor said what's he
comfortable with
he is comfortable with what he
feels like is right so he won't tell me
he he says you know i'm not going to get
as drunk as i used to
but i also don't want to be stuck to one
or two drinks a month
so here's the nightmare that is all of
our lives
we fall head over heels in love with
somebody we get up in front of
our friends and family some rando pastor
somewhere
and our grandparents show up the ones
who are still alive
and if we're religious we get in front
of god and say
i'm right or die with this one
and then you go home and realize i can't
control them
then you got kids and it gets even worse
and so what i will tell you right now is
any sort of behavior change predicated
on that's balancing on
what you're gonna allow for him will not
work
and that's heartbreaking
yeah and it's something tells me
that there is a
basically he's been told you got to
change your whole life your friends
your community the way you engage with
the world all has to be different or
you're going to
be dead and
as his wife the person looking in that's
easy
fix it right because your decisions are
going to affect me
but there is an unconscious decision
when faced with
a major life change of change all of
your life
or be dead there is an unconscious
[Music]
i'll play the dead card i don't believe
it happens to other people
yeah that will deal with it later that's
a problem for you know future husband
it's not worth the immediacy of i need
to see my friends today
i miss a dark smokey room i i-i-i which
means when you're living out of a you
can't do these things
it's always a fail that's why
restrictive diets fail 100 of the time
they just fail
right right versus hey
me and you have to go create an entire
new universe what we're about
who we are more importantly where we're
going why we're going there
and what that picture is going to look
like
and you have to be as equal co-creator a
co-author a co-painter of that picture
as he
is as long as you're on the outside of
this thing
barking orders at him directing him then
it's it's a you become his mom and
nobody wants to
be married to their mom right and nobody
wants to be married to their son
it becomes hey we gotta just read you
the whole thing
so you're there in new york the analogy
i use all the time usually it's when
like after infidelity you may have heard
me say this on the show
you cannot take this is a before and
after moment just like the last caller
everything was okay until his heart said
i'm out right
till you heard the man of your of your
life
almost to be dead and you're in the bed
that you sleep in
okay and i'm being intentionally direct
here okay
yeah you you got to go back and look at
911 with the twin towers you could never
sweep up
all that glass and twisted steel and
metal and recreate those towers with
those same ingredients you can't
the only thing you can do is take two
years
excavate the whole thing clean it all
up completely wipe that slight clean
and then get some great architects build
something new
design and build something new and now
that new tower is strong
it's powerful it's beautiful it's a
monument to what was
and it's a arrow pointing to the future
right that's what you'll have to do
the last data i looked at and i think
this is back in 2013's it's been a while
was faced with a terminal decision men
adult men
two out of seven made the behavioral
shift
wow which is dreadful numbers so number
one don't hold me to that data that's
the last i remembered
um and it could have shifted up by then
number two
that tells me that the behavior the this
or that
isn't the issue the issue is
the ecosystem the relationships the what
that means
that's what matters and
so what y'all have to do is the hard
work of saying all right we're starting
from square
square one square zero i mean except
we're already in it together and i'm
gonna heal
you're gonna heal but we gotta reinvent
this thing from the floor up
okay and here's where that really is a
risk for you sarah he could say i don't
want to
yeah he said that the other day
okay so what do you tell me about that
um i spoke to him about how i
was talking to my therapist about what
i'm comfortable with with
the drinking and stuff like that and he
said
you know i don't know if i'm willing to
do that and you're probably going to
leave me anyway because i don't think
i'm willing to do that
there you go and then later that night
he said you know we probably have a good
10 or 20 years left
but then you're going to leave me and
here's what happened and again i'm not
blaming i'm walking alongside you
you promise you you get me that on that
okay oh of course yeah
when it becomes a i'm not comfortable
with this that creates a you versus
me okay that becomes a right side and a
wrong side
and him saying oh well i mean if you
drew a line yeah eventually i'm gonna
screw this up
and so and since it's you versus me
you're just gonna leave
and that's where an excavation process
is no we're doing this together this is
us
and so similar to the last caller what
you got to do is you got to take him out
somewhere
and say i set this whole dynamic up
wrong
i said i'm going to let you do some
behaviors
that i'm comfortable with and i said
that wrong and i shouldn't have drawn
that boundary between us
i should draw boundaries around us but
not between us
and so what i what we have to do
together
is reimagine tomorrow completely new
from the flora
that means we may have to get new
friends i don't think so i think though
our friends will make adjustments with
us
we may have to move towns we have to get
new jobs we may have to
look at everything from the floor up
because i'm not living my life without
you i don't want to
i want you in it not you can't you can't
and i don't know a lot of people that
walk away from that conversation because
that's different than
if you don't then i'm gonna that's
different then hey i'm in it
i'm in it ah a minute
and then you gotta hold on the other
side man that's a risk that you're
taking
because he can look at you and say hey
you know what i'm out i'm not i'm not
doing that
i'm out let's deal with that when we get
there
my guess is that's not going to happen
my guess is when he hears your heart
your willingness to
go with him and you all go to a new
therapist it's not making you do these
weird thought experiments about
pretending your husband's dead but that
is about
all right let's clear the deck and build
something incredible and new
we're going to paint pictures together
we're going to live into those things
man this is our moment to dream about
what we were going to do and what we
should have been doing but let's do it
now
let's move to kansas you don't have to
move to kansas
but whatever that's going to look like
now we're all in
you're stud sarah
he's lucky to have you and let's
back this thing up and start all over
again
all right let's go to one more call
let's go to carol in omaha carol what's
going on
well i'm glad to be talking to you and
that last call was uh
pretty close to home so but on a
different subject but anyway
i am a widow i got four grown four grown
children a passport grandkids
and until recently i kind of thought i
had raised all my
children especially with um really solid
values
okay and i'd always felt like those 25
years of being mostly a stay-at-home mom
were
you know me living my true purpose in
life
and through the years i've uh you know
they might
as they were growing and declaring
themselves adults i
have been given many lessons on how to
let my grown children and then my young
adult
grandchildren make their own decisions
as adults
it's not easy but one new development is
just really kind of just breaking my
heart on a lot of levels
so here goes one of my sons and his wife
have recently discovered a lucrative way
of making a living that involves
gathering
fans of her online photos
uh fans only only fans
yeah okay i have no idea i'm not asking
those questions
they just told me they told me they were
probably not the kinds of
photos that i need to see and i
don't want to put them in an album and
show them to my mom and say here break
on your grandchildren
why hey why did they tell you this how'd
this come up over pancakes
like hey mom by the way i opened a
so only fans is a site that
like stay-at-home moms or anybody can
use but yeah it's
it's uh this wouldn't even tell people
what it is in case they look it up well
i mean it's it's it's common knowledge
for
those younger than you and me yeah yeah
um
yeah anyway it came up because um
she was able to i mean she's earning a
lot of money
they are earning a lot of money and he's
in you know i mean
they are in it together they're making
it their business and she
she quit her job that's how it came up
and they were suddenly not
pinched for money and so anyway
okay so there's a lot of i still don't
think i would
hey mom guess what i still bro i don't
know
um that's beside the point yeah well we
can we can go back to that if we need to
no i'm good on that so how can i help
okay so you're always talking about
people needing relationships and
community and stuff and this one tells
me
how do i build a community of friends
when this is part of what i
really need need friendships for no this
one's
it's i mean i was really proud
of raising my kids i was really proud of
myself as a mom probably too proud
hey carol carol kill carol carol
you didn't fail oh yeah carol
carol you didn't screw up
you didn't fail
that one's carol
you didn't fail
well i can't really say i feel like i've
succeeded
carol you didn't fail
success of raising your kids is
not hinge on the fact that they're going
to make only great decisions for the
rest of their lives
your time at home with them wasn't
wasted
you stepping in the gap when your
husband passed away
all of that energy and tears and
exhaustion
and late nights was not wasted
you didn't fail they're making decisions
that you don't like
but you and you didn't blow it
there's not something you could have
gone back and and
altered or twisted or changed that would
have shifted this outcome
so you gotta exhale
and drop your shoulders on that one
when you go back and blame yourself what
that does
is it allows you an illusion of control
that you had any control over the way
your
son or daughter or daughter-in-law
chooses to live their life in the first
place
and sometimes that lack of control is
scarier
than blaming myself for failing
and so i need if nothing else i'll give
you my thoughts on
your daughter and daughter-in-law and
your son but nothing else
you didn't fail you loved the crap
out of that kid all four of them
that is very true and i still do love
them of course you do i love
my grandkids i love you know i love my
my in-laws i mean and listen
because you're your son and
daughter-in-law let's just stick with
your son
okay because your son is
making different um
value choices than you yeah morally
moral choices than you
um doesn't mean you didn't raise him
with values
that's not what that means true it
doesn't mean
any of this is an indictment on you
at all so
then you fast forward and say i don't
like
the idea of my son and his wife
running a pornography business out of
their house that makes me as their mom
a little bit weirded out i'm
uncomfortable with that
that makes me angry that makes me
frustrated that makes me want to go
hit my son upside the head with a fly
swatter whatever the thing is
right so when i get
faced with those moments number one i
always go back
to like you mentioned relationship who
can i sit down and say this
really stinks who can i say that with
and it sounds like you're embarrassed to
tell your friends
that your son's doing this and here's
the thing
if you have friendships that you are
embarrassed to be fully you in they're
not real friendships
they're pretend ships i just made that
word up i should i should i should
coin that i just made that up it's a
pretend ship it's not real yeah
it's got a it's got a ring to it i like
it i'm gonna make a t-shirt
if you can't call your friend and say
hey i
i'm saying universal now oh my gosh i
cheated on my husband
we gotta talk now if you can't call your
friend up and tell them that they're not
your friend
that doesn't mean your friend's gonna
sit down and go what are you doing
you're an idiot you're more on you
that's what friends should be doing
holding each other accountable but you
gotta be able to tell your friends the
good stuff and the bad stuff
not just the pretend stuff and my guess
is
you've got friends that would hear this
and
weep with you and be sad with you and be
brokenhearted with you
and then would tell you oh yeah well my
son did x
my son-in-law i mean my daughter-in-law
did why
you'd probably find some community you
didn't know you had
and then the other thing is have you sat
down to talk to your son
and said this breaks my heart
um i've i've talked to him some but
i haven't actually been that
straightforward
okay so there's a moment where you're
gonna have to decide
the or what
right so let's pretend that your son
comes and you all have a conversation
and you say honey i just need you to
know
this breaks my heart that you and your
wife have chosen
this is the way you are going to make
money this breaks my heart
um i raised you to keep your sexuality
private between you and
and your spouse and y'all are
putting out for the world to see and
again i'm that's assuming that's what's
going on here right um yeah and it
breaks my heart
and then here's the or what so is it
going to be
so until you all take that sight down
you're not welcome at my home
i don't want you at family gatherings i
don't want you at thanksgiving i don't
want you at christmas i don't want to
see her face
is that or what or is he or what this
breaks my heart
and i don't talk about it anymore and
if i ever look sad it's because of that
but i love you guys
it's y'all's life to live and
um i'll be here now when y'all are
making a bunch of money and i'll be here
now when this thing goes
off the rails someday like those are the
two or what's right
and it helps to know up front because
what i see parents do
is they get in these conversations and
it gets loud and it gets emotional and
gets vulnerable
and then they say something they can't
take back yeah
no i mean the i mean we've
we've been through enough conversations
that i didn't like to have
that it definitely is the latter of the
two i mean it's
the one of my is one of my questions
um you know it's like how do you
talk to the grandkid i mean they've got
two little kids
preschoolers you don't that's not your
story to tell
okay i mean that's yeah i agree
if those kids if those kids i mean
you talk to your parents right it's
think about something more benign like
you don't
well that could be equally that's just
not your story to tell your job
your job is to love those kids sideways
and forwards and ups and downs like
you spoil the snot out of those kids
right that's your job
yep okay and if they ask you hard
questions
like hey we walked in and there's a
there's a photography studio i wonder
what's happening
that's you tell your son hey you're
you're my grandkids are asking questions
you're probably gonna need to ask
hard conversations about what mommy does
for a living and i if your son called me
i would tell him
do not lie to your kids right
and so that's i mean he wants to call me
he's welcome too but
that's not that's not your job okay
that helps yeah all right
what else well i appreciate this what
else
how about this carol i i have to know
what is your or what
um can you call both of them
and just and have a face to face with
them
yeah and just say i love you guys
y'all are always welcome in my home if
and
if you're a real gangster grandma you
could say and i'm going to make fun of
y'all
all the time that's how i handle sadness
that's how i see it i was i was
wondering if i
if i could push you know like kevin some
family
counseling on the issue so i mean we've
never we've never been a family that
really goes to counseling that much
but well hardly ever i don't
again if if they don't see this as a
family problem to solve
you're inviting them into your
boundaries you're inviting them into
your heartbreak
they're not heartbroken they called
their mom and told them
right now if you want to be super
gangster in person
go to the site go to the site and be
like yeah those pictures aren't great
i mean carol don't do that that'd be
awful for everybody
don't do that but you know what i'm
saying i don't want to have that in my
head
i that's a you're a wise wise wise woman
but but here's the thing you can't
control it
and so what that means is you need to
get a friend or two in your life you can
be honest with
invite them over make it a whole thing
and just say
i don't need you to fix nothing i just
need you to tell you i'm heartbroken
because my son
and his wife are making some decisions
that break my heart
and you're gonna feel powerless and you
have solved every problem known to man
for the last 20 years
and you can't solve this one
yeah that's part of
what you learn to live with that's right
that's right
and then yeah that hey that's the best
noise
right and you got to make that noise in
the presence of somebody else who will
still love you
right and i want to say it again i'll
say it again i'll say it again
this is not your fault
they made choices adult grown-up choices
they got two little kids
and they're making adult grown-up
choices
and then now you get to make adult
grown-up choices
be thoughtful understand what your or
what is going to be
control what you can control and get
around people that care about you to let
you be fully you
and it will still love you that will be
fully you
and will laugh with you and cry with you
and be angry with you and
make that noise with you yeah and then
love the snot out of those grandkids and
you let their moms and dads have those
hard conversations that's not your job
but i think you need to have a open
direct conversation with them because
it's going to haunt you until you do and
one out of love
one out of not resignation and anger
but one that just says
man you're awesome carol thank you for
being a mom that stepped in the gap
being a single
mom is oh god almighty you raised four
good ones
it's tough all right so as we wrap up
today's show thanks for that call carol
so i remember back when i was a kid
early 90s
it was the bridge between hair metal
and what i would call real metal
metallica and pantera and those guys
set the world on fire there's these
three kids
from the northwest and they came out
with this loud loud song
and nobody knew what they were saying
ladies and gentlemen i'm here to tell
you the song that changed the world
the greatest song ever written off the
1991
never mind record the one that brought
us from then
till now nirvana
smells like teen spirit check out this
poetic lyrics good folks
load up on guns bring your friends it's
fun to lose and to pretend
she's overboard and self-assured oh no i
know
a dirty word hello hello
hello how low hello
with the lights out it's less dangerous
here we are now
entertain us i feel stupid and
contagious
here we are now entertain us a mulatto
an
albino a mosquito my libido
yeah hey hello
hello hello i feel like my mind is blown
this has been the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you